-I'm so happy you're here! -I'm on "Jimmy Fallon"?!
Oh, my gosh. -Oh, my gosh. Come on.
-Wow. I can't believe this right now.
You guys have no idea. -No, please.
-No, no. It's just so exciting.
I'm in the chair.
-You are in the chair. We're doing this.
I met you last year
at Justin Timberlake's golf tournament.
-That's right. -It was 8:00 a.m., right?
-Yeah, the 8AM Tournament in Vegas.
-How fun was that? -It was so much fun.
-That was one of the most fun things.
And you were so funny and you were so nice and cool, and we --
I think -- Did you end up winning?
-Yeah, that's right. You know, what's funny about that
is one of the prizes at the golf tournament was two tickets
to "The Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon."
-Yeah. -And I won those tickets.
-You won them. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ] -So I -- Thank you.
You think I'm here for "Ant-Man."
I'm really here because I won two tickets
at a golf tournament. And I brought my mom.
She's in the audience tonight.
-Your mom actually is -- [ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. -Where's Mom?
Hi, Mom!
[ Cheers and applause ] -That's right.
-But that's not what -- -And that's why I'm here.
-That's not why you're here. -I thought that it'd be okay
if I sat up here, you know, for a minute.
-Of the two tickets that you're using.
-Just to talk for a second. -So you're only
using one ticket then use another one tomorrow?
-I can come back, right?
-You can come back whenever you want.
-Thank you.
-You're a great golfer, by the way.
-Thank you. You are, too. And you know what?
It's a dream to be here tonight.
So, I just remembered that you had that great bunker shot.
You know, the one that you made? You made one shot.
-The one they showed on the show every day
for like three months? -I know the feeling.
So, to honor that amazing shot, I got something for you.
I got you a custom wedge.
And it says "Jimmy's Lucky Wedge" on it.
Look! -This is insane.
You don't have to get me anything.
-And I put little ants -- Well, I wanted --
-That is so nice. -Now it's really lucky.
You're always going to be lucky now.
-Now it's part of my bag. It's in my bag forever.
-I got you a driver with Cassie Lang's power suit,
her super-suit colors. -No.
-So you can hit it like a superhero just like me.
-Exactly right.
-Yeah, and then next year, you know,
maybe I'll have to try a little harder to beat you.
-Yeah. Who did win? Oh, no. You know who won?
-Mahomes. -Mahomes and Kelce.
-Mahomes, I'm coming for you.
-Yeah, we're coming for you, Mahomes -- this year.
a-Yeah, that's right. -When did you start golfing?
Here. This looks like you're very young.
-That's me and my dad.
-Aww. -In my little Ralph Lauren.
You know, I've been golfing my whole life.
It's just -- It's my backup plan. You know?
-Yeah, exactly. Right? -Yeah.
-I mean, you played at some of the most iconic courses,
but you went viral for this shot that you made at Pebble Beach.
-I did. -Watch this.
And, yeah, listen.
-Oh, God. -Oh, nice swing.
-Yeah. -What a swing there.
-God, what a good swing. -Where's that going, Steve?
-It's a million-dollar hole, you know.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you kidding me?!
[ Cheers and applause ] -Well, thank you. Thank you.
-And was that Bill Murray? -That was Bill.
You know, that's where the two things
that I do really come together.
'Cause I was acting like a pro golfer.
I'm really not a -- I'm okay.
That was the only good shot I hit all day.
It's the only one that's on TV. -That's all you need.
-Yeah, they would show my swing and then cut away
so that no one saw where the ball went.
But I really had to pull it together, you know?
Bill and Macklemore were cheering me on.
They were like, "Kathryn, let's go."
And I was like, "Okay."
So it's the only good shot I hit that day.
-So, you hear Bill Murray go, "What a swing."
-I know.
-Is there pressure golfing with Bill?
-You know, the pressure was not Bill, but the pressure was TV.
I was, like, "I got to show everyone I'm a real golfer."
And Bill was like, "Kathryn, you're just an actor.
It's okay." [ Laughter ]
And then I hit that great shot after he said that.
-And then you're like, "Am I? Or am I great a golfer?"
-"Am I a good golfer or am I an actor? I don't know."
But then a couple months later, my mom's like,
"Kathryn, I have Bill Murray for you."
I'm like, "What? Bill Murray?"
She's like, "Yeah. Here."
And he's like, "Kathryn, I've been thinking.
I think I want to join the Marvel Universe.
And I was just gonna ask you if it was okay
if I join "Ant-Man."
And I was like, "Uh, yeah, Bill, that's cool.
That's cool with me.
Maybe there's someone else to talk to."
But I think he had, like, an offer,
and he was just calling to be like,
"Are we gonna play golf together?"
Michael Douglas golfs, as well.
We didn't get to golf, though,
because London, you know, it was rainy.
And it turns out Marvel movies are very intense
and I didn't want to golf.
[ Laughter ] -Yeah. You didn't want to.
Yeah, but, I mean, you're in a Marvel movie.
You're in one of the biggest things,
machines in the whole wide world.
They make the best, most fun movies.
What happens when you get that call?
And you're like -- you're going to be in "Ant-Man and the Wasp."
-Well, you know, they told me that I got the offer,
and I didn't believe it.
And then I got the announcement.
I saw it, you know. Still didn't believe it.
Then I had to hold it as a secret for a year
while we filmed the movie, and I still didn't believe it.
And then I watched it last night,
and I still don't believe I'm in the movie!
-You are definitely in the movie.
-I saw my name. It was on there.
The Marvel Comics. I'm like, "What?!"
-Yeah. -And then it said my name.
And I'm like, "Are you sure?" -Yeah.
-Doesn't even look like me, really.
But it's me. -It is you.
Paul Rudd, who is -- -Is the best.
-Friend of the show. One of the funniest --
-Funniest person in the world. Behind you, Jimmy.
-Thank you. Of course. Thank you.
And you. Then Paul Rudd. So, third.
-Yeah, third. -But he plays your dad.
-Yeah. -How is he to work with?
-How lucky am I? -Yeah, I mean, please.
-I mean, yes, it was a dream come true
to be a part of the Marvel Universe.
But then I got Paul Rudd. I laughed every day on set.
You know how great he is. -He's ridiculously funny.
-He made me funny, you know? He brought it out of me.
And I couldn't have asked for a better experience.
No, never.
-Did you ruin takes by laughing?
-Oh, for sure.
Actually, I'm a little mad at him because I can tell --
I laugh in every single scene in the movie.
Like, I break in every scene.
And there was one day we had 500 extras.
Okay? 500!
We had 10 explosions, bombs, fire.
Serious stuff where you can really, really get hurt.
And I was nervous. He could tell.
And he looked at me, and he's like, "Are you nervous?"
I'm like, "Yeah." He's like, "You got this.
You can do it. Whatever you do, don't laugh."
"Action!" Couldn't stop laughing.
I couldn't stop. I couldn't keep it together.
-That's the perfect way to do it. "Just don't laugh. Action."
-He was the worst.
The worst part is like -- it's not even a funny joke.
-But it gets you the giggles, then you can't stop.
-Yeah, I got the giggles.
So then there's bodies flying, dirt flying.
The director, Peyton Reed, is like, "Kathryn?
Are you smiling? Are you laughing?"
I'm just smiling ear to ear
as people are dying and explosions are happening.
-You can't use any of this material.
"We can't use any of this, Kathryn."
-No. Hour reset.
Paul's just laughing at me like, "Ha-ha. Got you."
I got him back, though. I did make him break.
And you know he's really good at not breaking.
So I got him back. -You got him to break?
-Yeah. You know, it's not bad.
-Got Ant-Man to laugh. -Yeah.
-How do we set up the movie?
-Okay. -"Quantumania."
-So, if you're a fan of "Ant-Man,"
you know you're going to laugh a little bit.
And you've got Cassie Lang and her dad reconnecting.
It's the heart of the story.
But the movie -- I just saw it. It's huge.
It's way bigger than I thought.
-Really? -Like, Kang -- It's amazing.
I love the movie, and I think everyone's going to love it.
-Okay. Good. Alright. Good. I want to show a clip.
This is a big deal!
Here's Kathryn Newton
In "Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania."
Take a look at this.
-You know, I promised your mom that you would only use
this stuff when one of us was around.
It's really dangerous tech. -I know it's dangerous.
-What if the cops took it from you?
Hmm? What if you lost it? -I didn't lose the suit!
-You have a suit? Wait. You have a suit?!
-I know how to take care of myself, okay?
Trust me. I'm pretty good at it by now.
-Ouch.
-Look, I didn't mean it like that. I'm sorry.
-I know. It's ok-- It's alright. I get it.
I just think you should get to have a normal life.
-Dad, a guy dressed like a bee tried to kill me in my room
when I was 6.
I've never had a normal life.
-How about some music?
-"And in that moment, all I could think was,
how did the Hulk turn me into a baby?
Will I be a baby forever? Am I the Hulk's baby?"
-Dad, are you listening to your own book?
-"But I was ready for anything." -Hmm?
[ Cheers and applause ] -Come on!
Thank you again for this.
-Thank you. -That is so thoughtful.
And, really, I'm so happy you're here.
Come back whenever. -I love it. I'd love to.
-You can bring Mom, too. -Okay.
-Kathryn Newton, everyone.
"Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania"
is in theaters and IMAX February 17th.